what's going on guys so if anyone's a
newer subscriber I actually do video
game reviews from time to time it's more
rare though because my channel is mainly
about movie and film reviews except from
time to time I will actually review a
game that I'm interested in playing and
that's really what it is I only review
games that I actually want to play
because I'm not going to sit around and
play every game that comes out because
it's just so expensive and it's not
really worth it but I do have a video
game collection mostly retro style games
I have n64 NES Super Nintendo and after
I made my blu-ray collection video
recently a lot of people were like Kris
why don't you show us some of your video
games cuz you're obviously into that too
we'd like to know what you think so I'm
going to take a trip down memory lane
with you guys into my childhood as I
talk to you about the system that is
most nostalgic for me my very first ever
video game system that I owned Nintendo
64 it basically holds all my favorite
childhood memories in regards to video
games I would play Nintendo 64 with my
friends and Super Nintendo and NES for
sure but Nintendo 64 was the one where
we were like wow 3d gaming and it just
really ushered in this new era at its
time it was the last cartridge based
system so that's pretty cool a lot of
things behind this n64 very special to
me I had all the Nintendo Power
magazines which I still have the way I
got my Nintendo 64 was for a long time
as a kid I wanted a basketball hoop
because I've always been a fan of
basketball and I play basketball quite
often but when I was a kid I always
wanted one in my driveway my parents
finally bought me one in like 1995 and
then we ended up moving from that house
and we couldn't keep the hoop and my
parents felt bad because I had finally
gotten one and they said you know what
since we can't keep your hoop as a
consolation we're gonna get you a
Nintendo 64 and to me that was like the
greatest thing ever and from then on I
had the best childhood ever and the
Nintendo 64 you have been seeing in my
videos is that one all the way back from
1996 when I bought it when my parents
bought it I was a child so let's get
started showing in my collection I don't
have like a humungous collection I have
a fair amount I have some of the best
ones out there in alphabetical order
starting with 1080 I was just doing the
voice
from the opening see the thing about
1080 snowboarding is what it's I guess
technically called everyone just call it
a 1080 is I wasn't really into sports
games but this game was so cool when I
first came out because the 3d graphics
because you could actually feel as if
you were snowboarding the fun techno
music I just really enjoyed this game as
a kid and I had a lot of fun playing it
basically tried to master like every
single one of the courses now let me
explain something about my game
collection I have them encased in these
really beautiful plastic collectors
cases which I got from a very cool
website called custom game cases this
website is pretty cool for me because
until I'm like 55 years old have a
mansion and I'm incredibly rich I'm not
going to be able to afford to case all
of my games with the original boxes and
instruction manuals that website custom
game cases allowed me to case my entire
collection for a very good deal and
they're just they look beautiful and it
makes me feel like I'm back in
blockbuster or Hollywood video like
actually looking through the titles and
everything and I can enjoy the cases if
you guys want to check out that website
to case some of your older games they do
NES Super Nintendo all different types
of games let them know the Kris sent you
the link is in the description below
because it's very reasonable and I was
actually able to case my entire
collection for a very good deal so I
definitely suggest checking them out
it's pretty awesome the next game in my
collection is one that maybe most people
don't remember I played it because I was
really into like bug killing games when
I was a teenager and I still kind of him
actually whenever they make a game like
just kill all the bugs I'm like yes
because I hate bugs are Marines
this was a game that you know like I
said not too many people probably
remember oddly they decided to give it a
black case I'm not sure why this game in
particularly on a different case now
these next three I'm actually gonna
group into one thing I have army men air
combat army men Sarge's heroes and army
men
Sarge's heroes - I am kind of a
humongous fan of the army men franchise
I wish they'd make more of them nowadays
and I don't know what it is
I just find it entertaining to play as
the little plastic guys going through
household objects and one of my favorite
army men games actually isn't on the n64
it was on the Gamecube it was army men
RTS it was basically like command &
Conquer for army men I don't know what
it was about those games as a kid I even
bought army man toys and made little
army man short films out in the wood
and my friends and I got a kick out of
doing that something about those games
just got me I don't wonder I think it
was the Toy Story element where you
could control toys and they had their
own little world and like a cup on the
ground was a base you know I just find
that pretty entertaining I don't know
why the next two games in my list are
pretty awesome they're pretty missed
algid for me and others I'm sure as well
these games are getting more and more
rare and more expensive retro games in
general it's one of the reasons why I
wanted to case my entire collection so I
could keep them safe from dust and
discoloration and whatnot but manjo
kazooie and banjo tooie is what I want
to talk about right now these are also
two games as a kid that I don't know
what it was like rareware
came out with so many great games in
that time period which we'll talk more
about some of them later that were just
so immersive and these huge worlds with
beautiful colored graphics enhanced by
the expansion pack on the Nintendo 64
which you know after a while they made
it so like certain games could only be
played on the expansion pack banjo tooie
is more expensive now than kazooie not
sure why they're it's like there are
fewer copies of it out there or more
people kept it or something I don't know
here's a game in my collection that I in
particular play that not a lot of other
people did it was kind of like I played
it my friends played it for a while but
I never really hurt anyone else talking
about this game I picked it up at an
older store that I don't see around
anymore called Value City I remember
back in the day it was like $20 there
you can find it now probably like five
bucks body harvest another bug killing
game which like I said in the late 90s
there were a whole bunch of them and
people really enjoyed them myself
included body harvest was this
time-traveling game where you could go
back in time to stop a bug invasion that
would eventually take over the earth
it's not a perfect game at all none of
these games I have gaming here that
aren't good like that I know that
they're just kind of nostalgic for me
speaking of games that aren't really
that great but are nostalgic for me
chopper attack now chopper attack you
could control a helicopter and basically
destroy all enemies in a field that was
the one mission objective you know
certain games if you just played them
for the first time now there's no way
you'd be like hey it's okay but when you
connect to the whole childhood nostalgia
to it it definitely enhances the
experience my next game on the list is
probably the only realtime strategy game
that i have for a nintendo 64 they
didn't make too many of them they made
starcraft 64 which is getting harder and
harder to find nowadays but they also
made a game called command
which was a port from the PC version my
biggest memory with this game is I spent
the night in my friend's house and we
stayed up pretty late and then all of a
sudden we were like hey why don't we go
to bed fairly early and by fairly early
we met like 1:00 a.m.
maybe so we could actually get up and
then play command & Conquer at like
10:00 and have a whole bunch of time to
play it all day and we actually did that
which was really rare for my friends
when we would always stay up to like
4:00 or 5:00 6:00 in the morning we're
like hey you got to leave it like 3:00
p.m. right right okay so why don't we
actually go to bed fairly early and then
we can wake up and play command &
Conquer for like five hours and we did
it and we had a lot of fun playing it
now the next game on the list I can't
really talk about without thinking about
the theme music it's impossible like
every single time I look at this game
all I think of is cruiser now Camden
cruisin USA is not a very good game it
has like retro 80s porn music in it like
there's seriously a song where girls
just like ooh
like I would literally be playing this
game hoping that my mom wouldn't listen
too close to the door and be like what
are you doing in your room because
cruisin USA has 80s retro porn music in
it but I had a lot of fun with this game
as a kid because my friends would come
over and we would cruise the USA
you could go to like each big place in
the USA and try to do the race and
everything
this next game on my list is one of the
most famous Nintendo 64 games this is
one of the first games inducted may
actually be the first game to require
the expansion pack it actually came with
the game it was a little more expensive
because of that and that is Donkey Kong
64 Z expansion pack included Donkey Kong
64 was another humungous hit by rare
where this game was huge I'll be honest
with you I still have not fully
completed this game like if you want to
actually get like 100% everything you
have to spend
I mean it's there's a lot of stuff in
this game it's extremely challenging
there's just one of those big roaming
worlds we can run around as Donkey Kong
the levels seemed huge as a kid like
just so expansive nowadays we have all
these games like The Last of Us and
Batman Arkham City where you can just
run around everywhere but these levels
when you were a kid it just felt so big
now this next game I actually didn't
play as much when I was a kid but I
became more of a fan of it as I grew up
and that is excitebike 64 see there was
an original game on the NES called
Excitebike that was really popular for
its time and really well-received it's
like by excite byte 60 excite bike
that's a hard title to say excite bike
64 was a pretty fun game with really
good graphics it had really good control
too that's one of the things I noticed I
played this game like a couple days ago
just to kind of play through some of my
games again so I could prepare for this
video and I couldn't believe how good
the control was like I really felt like
I was controlling a bike these next two
games are also racing games that I was a
big fan of as a kid Xtreme G 1 & 2 it's
filled with techno music filled with
these really fast-paced futuristic
tracks that I had a lot of fun playing
as a kid and still nowadays this game
has excellent replay value in particular
the first one the second one is still
pretty fun but the first one was always
the best for me when I was younger these
were some of the first really fast paced
racing games that
plate because even nowadays when I
played the track still feel pretty i
burning you know it gets into your
retinas the next game on my list is not
just one of the best intento 64 games it
is one of the best video games ever made
period one of the most revolutionary
video games ever made one of the most
influential video games ever made if you
ever sat down and played call of duty if
you are sat down and played any
first-person shooter that you had fun
with you have Goldeneye to thank for
that because this game is the game that
invented intense multiplayer
first-person shooter matches where you
got together with your friends and you
screamed at the computer all night as
your friend cheated with the rocket
launcher or got odd job and threw his
hat at you know the rumblepack know how
to use one of these and see how it feels
when double-o seven weeks and 64 and
it's not just the multiplayer that was
so great about this game the solo
missions are actually extremely fun
certain games you can tell it like one
thing is better than the other
maybe the solo is better maybe the
multiplayer is better this game has
equally fantastic everything the
soundtrack is so awesome the graphics
were very good for its time the reaction
from them as they got shot was cool I
remember as a kid I was like oh my gosh
like you can zoom in the leg and and
they like they like bend down and hold
their leg like it was crazy good
graphics and enemy reaction at the time
that it came out and it's probably still
the best game that was based off of a
movie that's ever come out because
generally those really suck hard if you
haven't played it that's pretty crazy
because you should know I don't really
consider this game a sequel to Goldeneye
but I mean I guess technically the world
is not enough is a sequel to it it was
taken over by a different company EA
games and they gave the game a blue
cartridge it fell out it's still a fun
game though it's definitely not bad game
it's just compared to the first one it
was it was like nothing okay now my next
game is probably the most rare Nintendo
64 games that I have I spent a long time
looking for this I finally found it used
for $50 I traded in some things to this
guy and I got it for 11 harvest moon 64
definitely one of the most hard to find
a Nintendo 64 games out there and the
reason for that is because the company
that produced this game just didn't
think it would sell that well because
it's such a weird John where you know
not too many gamers are going to be
interested in playing harvest moon 64 so
they didn't make that many copies of it
I vividly remember going to
Buster when I was a kid and buying it
for $2.99 can you believe that can you
whatever I have it now and I'm extremely
that I have it it's a farming life
simulator you know and I really have a
lot of fun with games like that because
so many games now it's like let's just
shoot everything let's blow everything
up okay that's great how about we plant
some seeds and take care of my dog and
meet some people in the town and grow
some fruit like I it's they don't make
games like that anymore unless it's a
Harvest Moon game of course and this
game is incredibly nostalgic for me and
I'm so glad that I have it because it
took me a long time to find it my next
game is more than likely the most
nostalgic game I have I don't know what
it is about this game I absolutely
adored everything about this game when
it came out in 1999 the soundtrack to
this day is still I think one of the
best game soundtracks ever made it's by
rare where it's another bug killing game
it was so immersive and incredibly long
and the graphics were so impressive when
I was a kid I to this day still haven't
gotten enough of jet force Gemini I
don't know what it is like something
about this game just makes me so happy
whether you play as the man Juno the dog
lupus or the girl Bella you can control
them all to go across these planets to
beat the actual game the game was
released along with Donkey Kong 64 and
almost the exact same time both by
rareware and Donkey Kong kind of
overshadowed this game and that's one of
the reasons why I didn't receive the
success that I think it personally
deserves I think it's one of the most
underrated games ever made now my next
two games on my list are some of the
most popular games ever created many
people refer to one of them at least as
possibly the best video game ever made
and that game is Legend of Zelda the
Ocarina of Time one of the most
immersive all-out humongous worlds where
you truly felt as if you were just in a
world you could control link you could
go to all these different places these
forests these castles these dungeons it
was so incredible and oh my god the
water temple don't even get me started
on the water temple oh the version of
this game that I do have is the gold
cartridge it is so beautiful looking and
its sequel Legend of Zelda Majora's Mask
continued in its reign of awesome the
cartridge that I have for this one is
the lenticular holographic gold one
which is so cool because that's pretty
hard to find nowadays these games are
getting harder and harder to find and
more and more expensive and they both
had this awesome kind of creepy vibe to
it you know
in the first one the skeletons would
come out at night the second one had all
those masks and the moon was in the sky
with that face and before I even tell
you what the title of my next game is I
just want to say that when you shoot
someone in this game you hear a voice
that actually goes like way to go go
why that's in Mission Impossible but
Mission Impossible man I'm a big fan of
the franchise okay this game came out
it's fun it's not a terrible game
actually by any means it actually isn't
a terrible game it's just it has like
these really cheesy elements to it that
the amazing like 1990s I got shot sound
effect ah there were in like every game
back in the day you play as Ethan Hunt
you you do various missions that are
somewhat like the movie and then there
are these random ones that have nothing
to do with it it's an entertaining game
it's more nostalgic for me probably than
it is special here's a drinking game for
you
take a drink every time I say nostalgic
in this video you'll get pretty hammered
now following Goldeneye people were very
keen to emulate that success and very
few people did it correctly but one game
actually did it very well and it just so
happens to be from the makers of
Goldeneye rareware so that works because
Perfect Dark is probably the second best
first-person shooter on the Nintendo 64
in fact it definitely is and it is one
of the best FPS has ever made for sure
they made a more mature version of it
with more blood I remember I played it I
was like this is basically Goldeneye
with a girl which is awesome oh but
blood pools beneath him Wow before I
show you what the next game is let me
explain this is actually the very first
video game I was ever given my first
exposure to this game was when I went to
Blockbuster and they had a TV set up
with a Nintendo 64 controller and you
could play a version of this game and I
thought it was just the coolest thing
I've ever seen in my life and my parents
bought it for me back then it was 50
bucks
that game is starfox 64 this game has
some of the best replay value I have
ever encountered in my life I love
hearing Falco make jokes about how he's
awesome and how Fox is dumb
I guess I should be thankful and have
Pepe constantly getting his butt kicked
they're on me I'm getting careless
thanks Fox and as slippy scream like a
little girl in fact for the longest time
and as a kid I thought slippy was a girl
Star Fox 64 is one of the coolest
rail-based games ever and that's where
you know a thing is controlling you on a
certain path you can't deviate from it
you just have to shoot as many of the
ships as you can in one I eventually got
all the medals on each level which is
controlled by how many enemies you shoot
down then I got the expert mode and I
got all the medals on that like it's one
of those games where you just feel like
you have to complete it this next name
on my list was not an official sequel to
Star Wars Rogue Squadron but to me it
was star wars battle for Naboo this game
was a lot of fun it had the same basic
structure as Star Wars Rogue Squadron
but you controlled things that were
going on in the episode one universe not
a lot of people played this as much as
Rogue Squadron I'm not sure why it's one
of the games like starfox
where you feel the need to complete each
level and then get the bronze and silver
and gold medals and even platinum
there's a platinum medal also coming
from the Star Wars Episode one universe
was Star Wars Episode one racer a racing
game you know you did the podraces you
could be anakin you could be other
characters one thing about Episode one
for sure the games for it definitely had
a special place for me as a kid because
I loved playing those games battle for
Naboo and racer if you tap are over and
over again you can hear Anakin say stuff
just to let you know and I was referring
to it earlier and here it is Star Wars
Rogue Squadron one of the best Star Wars
games ever made and we're the most
entertaining ship shooting whatever the
genre is game's definitely a game with
incredible replay value you could play
this game over and over again and still
feel the need to play it like battle for
Naboo like Star Fox
these shooting in the sky with ship
games really made me feel the need to be
a completist about it and do everything
you could do and beat every level and
get all the gold medals and everything
and my last Star Wars game on this list
and I believe the only Star Wars game on
the Nintendo 64 that I have not talked
about is star wars shadows of the Empire
this game is weird because it's stars -
render who's that he's the guy from the
shadows of the Empire book it has
characters in it that you're not sure
like who are these people prince
she's or I guess is how you say it as a
kid I was like X I Ora
what does that mean but as soon as
you're running around his - friend are
through Gauss spaceport - shootin
stormtroopers off of cliffs and you hear
them do that great ah whatever that
sound is I don't know it's awesome
now for many people the next game I'm
going to talk about is the game that
people played for the very first time on
the Nintendo 64 the very first
experience people had with real 3d
graphics I mean there were other games
that were 3d like Star Fox for the Super
Nintendo but this game is really the
first time where someone put it in and
went wow I don't even know what I've
been missing cuz in all honesty I think
possibly the biggest jump in graphics
was probably from Super Nintendo 2
Nintendo 64 I mean they were just such a
huge jump I mean from GameCube to Wii
and from ps2 to ps3 it's a big jump but
going from playing Super Mario World on
the Super NES to playing super mario 64
people were pooping all over the place
and spreading it across the walls and
like across her face because they were
like freaking out and turning into crazy
people that probably didn't happen maybe
it did in somebody's house
I don't know but popping in this game as
a kid and running around just outside
the castle where you just wandered
around it hopped on trees and stuff and
looked at the cat it was just like wow
what is this like it was just such a
great experience another game where I
felt like a completist where I had to
get all 120 stars which I did do this
game had so many great level designs and
it was just the right amount of
challenging where you didn't hate
yourself but it wasn't easy and that's
another great thing about this game
revolutionary in every way so many games
have modeled themselves after this now
when I was a kid there were two games in
particular that I viewed as the ultimate
multiplayer experiences one of them we
had already talked about that's
Goldeneye 64 and the other one is Super
Smash Brothers this game introduced
playing as Nintendo characters and being
the crap out of each other
it was insanely awesome like no one
expected it to be as good as it was
everyone was like picturing this Street
Fighter one on one this one moving
cat-like it wasn't anything like that
the idea of being able to have moves
that you knew these guys could do and
pulling them off correctly and like when
you just barely make it back to a stage
hearing the crowd go oh you got the
feeling that people were actually like
watching these matches that added to it
as well every single game since then has
improved upon it all so that's a great
thing about that series melee was better
than this brawl was better than that
my opinion of course I'm not a huge
fighter game fan like fighting games are
fine I'll have anything wrong with them
but this is truly I think one of the
best fighting games ever made because it
changed the way fighting games could be
done nowadays I would never play a game
like this I would never to pick up a
random supporting game that I don't care
about but for some reason in the 90s
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater was extremely
popular to the point of people who
didn't skate like myself loved it like I
loved playing this game I've never rode
a skateboard correctly in my life but
for some reason really enjoy playing
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater it had a blue
cartridge which was pretty cool
it had cool music it had cool sound
effects it had good graphics for its
time and a really fun skating system
that obviously started a humongous
franchise now the only game I have in
this series is my favorite one and that
is Tarak two seeds of evil eventually
I'll probably get some of the other ones
this game really improved upon the first
one the dinosaur graphics were better
the interacting with them was better it
was more fun as a first person game this
is probably the best one in the series I
think um I have very vivid memories with
a game called wave race 64 this game for
me I played this game with a buddy of
mine in his attic quite often because he
had it but I didn't he had his Nintendo
64 in his attic and we would played this
game and tried to beat all the various
time trials over and over again another
game that for some reason antenna 64 had
this thing for me where I don't care
about jet skiing but I loved playing
this game terrific really impressive
water graphics one of the first times I
ever looked at water and thought wow
that water looks really real now lastly
here I have a couple loose games that
aren't boxed yet I will eventually pick
up boxes for them but those games are
pilot wings 64 a flight simulator game
where you could take control these
people and basically do these various
tests as you flied with these wings and
pilot piloted them with wings pilot
wings shadow gate 64 trials of the four
towers I actually had not played this
game yet
I bought this office somebody from
Craigslist for a very good price I
looked up some gameplay videos about it
and it really interested me so I'm gonna
play this very soon and last but not
least vigilante 8 a game in which you
could control a school bus and blast
other cars into oblivion it was kind of
like twisted metal except slightly
different it was like the 70s retro
style game that had all these in jokes
in there and
aliens I enjoyed all these games very
much Nintendo 64 is extremely nostalgic
for me it's a system that I played quite
often there's a reason it's behind me in
all of my videos I hope you guys did
enjoy this if you liked this I'm
planning on making one for my Nintendo
and Super Nintendo collection as well
that's not as big so I'm going to
actually bunch both of those into the
same video if you'd like me to of course
if you enjoyed this from time to time I
want to do video game things not as
often movies are my main focus but I'm
also a gamer at heart so I hope you guys
did enjoy this video and I am interested
in knowing do you guys have a gamer
story a game story that maybe isn't a
static to you some game in particular
that means a lot to you as a kid or
maybe as an adult
what's your gamer story because I
basically just told you mine and as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes